yesterday on the psychic network
don lemon said this about trump
supporters
stop saying that we must respect
trump supporters who believe bull
because
it is that you have been
feeding them the president and you
have been feeding them the bs and now
that they believe it all of a sudden you
again another self-fulfilling prophecy
and feedback loop
now in a world where the internet
doesn't exist lemon
might seem smart no such luck
donald trump couldn't find ukraine on a
map if you had the letter u and a
picture of an actual physical crane
next to it that's partly him playing to
their base and playing to their
audience uh you know the the the
credulous boomer rube demo that backs
donald trump
um that wants to think that that that
donald trump's a smart one and they're
y'all elitist
you will you elitist with your geography
and your maps and your spelling
even though my path and your reading
so after lemon was exposed for laughing
at a racial stereotype
he said this just to make this perfectly
clear
i was laughing at the joke and not at
any group
of people
fact is the deep hatred toward millions
of americans from the media
existed well before this election cnn
mastered it and tried to monetize it
it's the media's persistent irrational
venom toward trump supporters that
created the legit
suspicion that election fraud indeed
happened
i mean if you think the trump camp are
all white bigoted rubes or nazis
of course you're gonna rig the election
it's like that college mind game
if you could go back in time would you
kill a baby if that baby was hitler
sure you're killing a baby but hey it's
hitler so yeah trump supporters are so
dumb they'll believe anything you know
like that dossier which trump supporters
said had
compromising info on our new president
oh wait that wasn't trump supporters it
was cnn
back in january 2017 the same month
as trump's inauguration how about that
timing
or how about the time that trump
supporters said anthony scaramucci had
links to a russian investment fund
except that was cnn too sorry and
remember when trump
supporters incorrectly claimed trump and
his son don jr got early access to
wikileak documents oops i did it again
that was cnn brittany there's more where
that came from plenty more at least four
years worth of nonsense it seems like
cnn will believe anything
and call it news but only as long as
they can smear you with it ya rube
[Music]
so dana i mean the essential truth is
that
this kind of belief has always been
around and it's a cl it's a class
uh kind of hatred it's like you are too
stupid and uneducated
unlike me that's what you get that's the
vibe that you get it's not about race
really it's about class
i even kind of remember it you know
growing up in a rural area
um in the middle of the country i didn't
even see an ocean until i was 16.
i remember it then and hearing you know
my family talk about it they were
ranchers my dad subscribed to all the
magazines
including national review from way back
when and
you know so i've actually remember
hearing this from a long time ago and
then
of course a more recent memory my time
at the white house of course there was
that
but really i think it really intensified
greg with the tea party
and it never really ended um and i also
would say to this like
what don lemon is saying it means that
we shouldn't respect
anybody who believes that trump
illegally run won election in 2016 and
that the russians helped him do it
i mean if that if that's where they're
headed down however the good news is
this
i don't think anybody really cares what
don lemon thinks about them
like it's not it's not a big deal yeah
to them
that's a fair point martha do you care
about what don lemon thinks
it makes for a great segment
you know i think dana's right i think
that most people don't care what don
lemon thinks of them but
you know i i do think that when you look
at this this kind of
behavior and i think back to president
obama's comment which was
surreptitiously picked up of you know
mocking people who cling to guns and
religion
and and i think that there is this
divide obviously in the country between
uh the media and the people that they
love to chuckle at and speak down to
and that's it goes back to what i was
talking about in the beginning of the
show
you know anyone who thinks that oh you
know that that beast has been
has been stabbed in the heart and that
is over is completely wrong
uh they're completely wrong there are 74
million americans who feel very strongly
about
the way that they look at the country
and the way they want the country to be
and you know they can chuckle all they
want and call people names but but this
this whole dynamic is not over it's far
from over
in the country it's a it's an
interesting point juan because we do
here on the five and elsewhere on on fox
there are people like me who make fun of
the leaders but we don't make fun of the
people who support them like we don't
say buying voters or a bunch of rubes
a bunch of dumb rubes you know i'll just
say democrats are just dumber
republicans
but that's pretty mild
right or so socialist and uh
and haters and all the rest but you know
it's pretty much look i
i listened to your monologue greg and i
think i have two questions for you to
consider
one is do you believe that the november
election
was stolen and two uh you know do you
think that
uh you know a dead hugo chavez rigged
the election
i think the answer for for everybody is
no that's not true
so you know when you think about it in
those terms when people
when people say oh yeah well this is
what i believe and i'm in a fury you
know you guys think well
do we have an obligation to say oh yeah
that's right you know
yes we're going to just go right along
with what you have to say
i think we don't put flat earth people
on tv
and say the earth is flat we want people
who are at least honest
and knowledge facts and reality joe
biden will be sworn in
as president on inauguration day
the most flat earth opinion is that
antifa is anti-fascist but we'll leave
it there